hello you guys uh today we doing a 2022
2023 uh Nissan
Maxima so in this case is uh
0722 um we're going to go to
immo add kilos to be the same just make
sure you're putting the hazard lights
on and then you can go into Nissan
and you can go automatic selection
regardless if it's a if it's add key or
Os so in this case it's an add key but I
can leave the ignition off and then
we'll just do the same
so after a good minute or so it's going
to be
over and then we're just going to go to
emo smart
system we're going to go to remote key
learning we're going to press smart key
learning we're going to turn off the
we're going to turn the hle lights on
which is on the ignition is off we can
open and close the driver the
runs and we're going to press okay
okay and we're putting a key on the push
to start and now we're going to press
and hold the push to start until the
cluster comes on when it comes on we can
let go and then we can press
okay now we're going to shut it off so
we're just going to press once ignition
is off and pressing
okay now we're going to take the first
key we're going to put it on the push
button just like that give it a small
click
the clust all comes on immobilizer light
flashes 5 seconds and then shuts off
then we're going to turn off the
ignition and we're going to press okay
this was the first
key now we're going to go to the memory
and hit memory two and do add take the
second key and do the same just press
wait for the cluster to come on the
immobilizer lat to flush five times and
shut it off
and put the key aside and press
okay in this case we're adding another
key so we're just going to go to slot
number three and we're going to do add
we're going to take the third key put it
on the push button wait for the light to
flash five
times goes away shutting off putting the
key here and pressing
okay now when we done we're just going
to hit next we can take the one of the
keys that they registered we're just
going to press it on the push button
cluster will come
on and then we can shut the cluster off
it's going to say key registration
completed and all of the keys should be
able to start the car by
now and this is how you do 2022 2023
Nissan Maxima adding a key all key lost
with the IM5 away thank you guys for
watching have a great day